PENN JILLETTE: Anyway,
welcome to this Google Talk.
We have Penn
Jillette here today.
You probably know him
from Penn & Teller.
Been on "The David Letterman
Show," Howard Stern.
And he's been on a
lot of other shows.
This is his latest book on
the New York Times best seller
list.
He did "Penn & Teller Bullshit."
And of course now, it's
Penn & Teller "Fool
Us," which abbreviates to
FU, which is the theme.
Could be coming
out very shortly.
We're so happy to have him here.
How about we give a nice
Google round of applause
to Penn Jillette.
Thanks so much, Phil.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Thank you so much, so much.
Thanks for that really
nice introduction.
That was a great introduction.
I'm so glad to see you here.
I'm gonna talk a little
bit about my book,
about how I lost a
wicked lot of weight.
But the first thing I gotta say,
the most important thing to say
to you is, if you take medical
advice from a Las Vegas
magician, you are an asshole
and you deserve to die.
Make that very, very clear.
I'm going to be talking
about a lot of stuff
I don't know jack shit about,
which is not unusual for me.
But I am going to be
talking rather seriously
about a lot of weight loss.
And these are serious
medical things.
So really, if anybody's going
to listen to a word that I say,
you really have to do
the research on your own
and talk to doctors and people
that actually know shit.
In 2014, around Halloween time,
I ended up in the hospital.
I had blood pressure
like UK voltage.
I was really looking like 220.
And that was on
five hard core meds.
And the doctor said
to me that I had
to lose about 30 or 40 pounds.
I was about-- at that
point, I was about-- well,
you don't weigh yourself
at the heaviest,
but I figure I weighed
in at about 333.
So I think I was
probably heaviest day,
probably about 340.
I'll give you some
advice, anybody here,
if you want to lose a lot
of weight, first gain a lot
of weight.
Because if you haven't
got 110 pounds to lose,
you have not got a chance.
So I was probably around 340.
I don't really know.
And I've been told for
years that the reason
I had high blood pressure
was that it was genetic.
They always said it was genetic.
And I do have in my
ancestry some the high risk
for high blood
pressure background.
I have a little bit of African
and some Native American.
And those are the ones
that do really bad.
What are you doing?
PHIL: Sabotaging you.
Sorry.
Just please go on.
PENN JILLETTE: No, no.
I just want to know.
This is exciting.
I want to know what exciting
sort of things you're up to.
Oh, you turned the
microphone up a little bit?
PHIL: Trying to.
I don't know if it'll work.
PENN JILLETTE: OK, good.
You couldn't get your own
fucking mic to work, so.
First take the log
out of your own eye
before finding the stye in mine.
At least my mic was
working somewhat.
You doing OK?
PHIL: Yeah, yeah.
Thanks.
PENN JILLETTE: It's not
like you're invisible.
I mean, it's not like you
walk like a Warner Brothers
cartoon up like this
and no one sees you.
PHIL: When you were over
there, I wasn't quite--
PENN JILLETTE: Oh, you thought
I was misdirecting from you?
OK.
Am I louder now?
Is that OK?
So I have some of those high
blood pressure kind of genes.
And the nutty thing was,
the doctor came to me
and said that I was going
to-- they were suggesting
that I get a stomach sleeve.
So they were going to give me
a surgical operation to make it
so that I couldn't eat as much.
And he said he wanted to
get me down to about 280
so that the meds
that I was taking-- I
was taking five medications
and at the highest dosage
to get it down to what could
be controlled by drugs.
And then I said to
him, well, you know,
what if I get down below that?
What if I get down
to about 230 or so?
And he said, well, if
you get down there,
you wouldn't need
the meds at all.
And I thought that
was really odd.
Because if this was
a genetic condition,
how could I get rid
of a genetic condition
just by losing the weight?
So I said, the drugs
that I'm taking
are not really high
blood pressure drugs.
They're fat fuck drugs, right?
I mean, they're just drugs
because I'm a fat fuck.
That's the reason I'm
taking these drugs.
And he said, well, I guess so.
I guess you could say that.
But you know, you'll
never get down.
You'll never get down to 230.
We're just hoping
you'll get down to 280.
And I did not say anything
about losing weight
when I was in the hospital.
As a matter of fact, when
he said stomach sleeve,
I said, sure, I'll do
that in a few months.
Whenever it's right, I can come
back in and schedule something,
get that operation.
Because I didn't want to make
any promises in the hospital,
because I do not
believe anything anyone
says in the hospital, on
New Year's Eve, or right
after they come.
And surprisingly, I say the same
thing in all three situations.
So I didn't promise anything.
I just thought,
well, maybe I'll see.
But what the doctor gave me
by saying stomach sleeve,
by saying that they were going
to do a surgical operation so
that I can lose weight,
what he said to me
had nothing to do with
the surgical operation.
It had nothing to do
with the procedure.
What it gave me was the
liberty to go crazy,
the liberty to be a nut.
Because what I'd
always thought was
I was supposed to lose
weight like a grown up,
like an adult, like the New
York Times wanted me to--
with slightly smaller
portions, and why not be
vegan after 6:00, had maybe
do an afternoon fast once
in a while.
It was all this
moderation thing.
And as soon as he brought
up they were actually
going to do a
surgical operation,
it gave me license to
be crazy, to look around
for something nutty to do.
And I realized at
that moment, when
he said they were going to
actually do a surgery, that not
only am I not good
at moderation,
it's easy to say that you're
not good at moderation,
but I also don't
respect moderation.
As a matter of fact, if
you're good at moderation,
I don't like you.
I think you're a boring asshole.
The only things
we brag about are
things that do not have
to do with moderation.
No one brags about taking a
casual walk up a grassy slope.
They brag about
climbing Everest.
And I realized that all
the people I admire,
all the people I look
up to, are people
who do not do moderation.
So I started sniffing around
to try to find some way
to lose the weight crazy.
And so all the stuff they
say to insult people who
lose a lot of weight
quickly, like it's a fad diet
or it's this or that, was
exactly what I was looking for.
I wasn't looking to just do
a little bit of something.
I was looking to do
something really intense.
And into my life-- not into
my life, but a friend of mine
showed up again about the
day before Thanksgiving.
He showed up again.
His name is Ray Cronise
I call him Cray-Ray,
because he's nuttier
than a shit house rat.
And he used to work at NASA.
He worked with astronauts.
And he's the one that took
me up in the Vomit Comet
when I got weightless.
So he's always been involved
in taking weight away from me.
Well, actually, not
the real Vomit Comet.
We actually set up what I think
now was in an illegal bootleg
Vomit Comet.
All I know is that on the
manifest when we took off,
it was an Air
Mexicali cargo plane.
Which doesn't seem
too official for NASA.
And it was at a little
kind of stupid airport.
And also on the
manifest, the two people
listed as mission specialists
were me and Billy Gibbons of ZZ
Top.
We were the brains
of the outfit.
So when you've a magician
and a blues guitar player
together in charge
of an aircraft,
you know you've got trouble.
But we did the parabolas
went weightless for a while.
And that was Ray
Cronise, who, as matter
of fact, when I was
on the Vomit Comet,
and when I realized I was gonna
go weightless-- I think I share
this with everybody--
the first thing
you think when you're
going to be weightless
is, boy, if I'm going
to be weightless,
I have got to strip naked and
sing the Barbarella theme.
Especially if Billy Gibbons is
there to play guitar, right?
Because, as we all know,
Barbarella, the '60s film,
Jane Fonda strips
naked while weightless.
Now, she's not
actually weightless.
See, here I am being that
skeptic, exploding those myths.
She's not actually weightless.
She didn't shoot like Apollo 13.
You know, she didn't
have Ron Howard doing it.
She just was on a piece of glass
in Hollywood, rolling around.
But I wanted to see
if I could strip naked
like Jane Fonda in zero G.
So Billy played guitar, and I
went Barbarella-- and they're
kind a little bit
surprised that I was
going to actually strip naked.
But if you look at my
resume, I'm not one to bluff.
So I was not only zero G,
but I was zero G naked.
And then I also-- as it's
called the Vomit Comet,
I also vomited.
And at that point, I had
hair down my back, and curly
and messy in zero G. So
I not only vomited naked,
but also vomited
naked into my hair.
And the person who
was videotaping that
was my buddy
Cray-Ray, Ray Cronise,
who also set up the
illegal Vomit Comet thing.
So he came back into my life
that Thanksgiving of 2014.
And he had been doing about
five years of research
with a bunch of real
academic people about really
extreme weight loss.
And they discovered a few
things that were really,
I would say counterintuitive,
but I don't think
they're counter-intuitive.
I think they actually
are intuitive.
They're just kind
of counterculture.
They found out a few
things, that the faster
you lose weight, the more
likely you are to keep it off.
And they also found that
radical changes in diet
were actually easier
for people to adhere to
than moderate ones.
And they had been taking
people through this program.
Now, they'd done very few
studies at this point.
They'd done about 300 or 400
people they'd put through this.
And as we all know
statistically,
a few hundred people
means nothing.
So the information
that you're getting--
what's weird about my book,
this stupid popular book
by a comedian came out before
the real science studies,
which will be coming
out in a year or two,
because I'm one of the
early people doing it.
So I actually got out into the
forum, into the public eye,
before the real scientists.
So all this stuff will be
backed up and then torn apart
by peer review after that.
Of course, my book is
also peer reviewed,
but I'm a Vegas performer.
So my peer is Carrot Top.
So Carrot Top looked over
the science in the book
and says it's OK.
But what Ray did for
me was he first of all
did two weeks on a mono diet.
Now, this is why when I
was on Good Morning America
they put Penn's potato diet
on the chyron underneath me.
It's a little bit of
an oversimplification
but a little bit interesting.
They put me on a monodiet.
Now, the monodiet
could be anything.
The monodiet could be rice.
It could be corn.
It could be beans.
But we chose potatoes.
And we chose potatoes
because they're funny.
So for two weeks I ate
nothing but potatoes.
Sweet potatoes,
regular potatoes,
but not anything
added or subtracted.
Which means not microwaved
and cut up so they lose water,
and with the skins
and everything.
I ate potatoes for two weeks.
And what that does that's
really interesting is,
it resets a lot of the
psychological and physiological
parts of eating.
Because it takes away
eating as entertainment.
Because eating potatoes
is not entertaining.
It takes away the social
aspects of eating.
Because nobody calls you
up and goes, hey, Penn.
I just got into Vegas.
Let's go have a potato.
At least it didn't happen to me.
And so after two weeks
of just potatoes,
I first of all lost a
huge amount of weight
and also felt better.
Day three and four, hell.
Because you get really lethargic
and sad and have no energy.
And then day five, you're
just bursting with energy.
I just felt fabulous
for the whole rest
of the time, the whole rest
of the time I lost weight.
Was about three months
I lost over 100 pounds.
Then I went to a very limited
diet, but not just potatoes.
And the first day after
my two weeks of potatoes,
I had corn on the cob.
And the crazy thing was I've had
corn on the cob my whole life.
But I had it after
two weeks of potatoes,
it actually seemed
to me like candy.
It was just so
sweet and so salty
and to actually taste food
that I've eaten my whole life
but without the butter, without
the salt, without the shit,
was just amazing.
It tasted so good.
And you just had two weeks,
just two weeks, just two weeks.
No time at all.
So much of me changed.
Foods that I didn't like to
eat before I was fine with.
Turns out, at least
from stuff I've
been reading, that all of the
food we eat is just habit.
There's nothing but habit.
There's no sort
of natural desire.
You eat what you were
brought up eating.
Grilled cheese sandwiches
are a comfort food
because they were given
to you as a comfort food
and you got used to it
for no other reason.
So after that two
weeks, I ended up
on the diet I'm on now,
which is no animal products.
I don't say that I'm vegan,
because I'm wearing a leather
belt. But I don't eat animal
products, no refined grains,
and extremely low
salt, sugar, and fat.
And after about
three months of that,
your microbiome changes, and
you don't have the cravings.
I mean, what I said
to Cray-Ray was
am I going to be able to
eat these foods that I love?
Am I going to be able to
have pizza, and hamburgers,
and that kind of stuff?
And Cray-Ray said,
well, you know,
what really matters about food
is what you eat chronically,
what you eat daily.
No one gets fat from
one meal, and no one
gets healthy from one meal.
So sure.
When it's rare and appropriate,
on special occasions,
on holidays, or with special
friends, eat whatever you want.
And I did that after I hit
my target weight, which
was on my birthday.
So I was in the hospital
October 31st, 2014.
On March 5th, 2015,
I was 229 pounds.
Now, from 330 pounds
we predicted 229 pounds
that we would hit
on my birthday.
We hit it one day before my
birthday to the exact amount.
Which to me is much more
impressive than NASA
hitting Jupiter.
Because it's done
by an idiot, which
you have to grade on a scale.
And then about two
weeks after that,
I went out and had a
rare appropriate meal.
And I went and ate
everything in the world.
I ate French fries and
hamburgers and chocolate
desserts and all that stuff.
And what amazed me
was, it was good,
but it wasn't like
falling off the wagon.
It wasn't like this is the way
I was going to eat forever.
It wasn't like I had
no control over it.
It was just like, OK.
That's a fine thing.
And what's happened
is it's now been--
and this is important
to keep in mind,
because the magic number on
weight loss is two years.
Two years, you're down
to 1% of the people that
keep the weight off.
Two years is kind of magic
in weight loss science.
And I'm now at 17 months.
17 months I have
kept the weight off,
and it doesn't feel like
it's coming back on,
but I don't want to exhibit
too much hubris on this.
I'm still careful.
But I realized-- and this
was just the past week, just
the past week.
I realized that I have no more
cravings whatsoever for meat
at all, even though I'm due
for a rare inappropriate,
I can eat anything I want,
the idea of eating chicken
is repulsive to me,
fish I don't want
to have at all, steak and
hamburgers went later,
but I still have
no desire for them.
Probably the next time
I eat whatever I want,
it'll be a hunk of chocolate,
maybe some spaghetti, maybe
a cookie.
It's gotten so, so easy.
And what I found is,
doing stuff that's
really intense and
hardcore when you have
a real difference in feeling
is so much easier than doing
stuff that's half assed.
Also, and nobody
knows about this,
I mean, so I can talk
very freely about this,
because no one
will contradict me,
because nobody knows jack
shit about the microbiome.
This is a whole
new area of study
they'll get to in a while.
But it sure seems like after you
don't-- I'm going to use some
technical terms here.
So try to stay with me.
After you've not
eaten meat and stuff
for a while, the cooties
that live in your guts that
eat meat and fat and
that kind of stuff,
those cooties, they die.
And then the cooties
don't send stuff
to your brain that
makes you crave them.
That's the way I understand it.
And I know that some
of the scientists
out are not using
the word cooties,
but that's seems like
the exact right word.
But there's magic
in the microbiome
as far as I can tell.
And after you change the
way you eat for long enough,
things inside you change.
So this is what happened to me.
And what surprised me probably
the most, and the thing I'm
most embarrassed about, about
this whole thing, is I'm
an atheist.
I'm a hardcore atheist.
And I certainly don't believe
in a mind-body separation.
I certainly don't
believe there's
any sort of soul or
anything supernatural.
I believe we are computers
made of meat and nothing more.
And yet, there was
some part of me
that seemed to not believe that.
Because when I was
really fat, I really
thought there was some
homunculus inside of me that
was driving this
big fat machine,
and that my mood and my
personality, and who I was,
was somehow different than the
body that I carried around.
And one of the things that
embarrassed me, and shocked me,
and surprised me was
after I lost 110 pounds,
I really was deeply
and profoundly happier.
And my mood was really
better all the time.
And I enjoyed things more.
And I didn't really expect
that to be the case.
I expected that when I
played with my children,
I enjoyed being
around my children,
and although it took a little
more energy to get going,
I still wanted to be with them.
I didn't expect to be happier,
and kinder, and just nicer.
I mean, not to Teller,
but to everyone else.
And it really made this huge
difference in my personality.
And I remember going
back to the Vomit Comet.
What people don't talk about
when they're being weightless,
when they're doing
this, is that in order
to do the physics
to be weightless,
when you're doing
this, you're at zero
G. When you go back
up, you're about 2 G.
And what I remembered
from that going on there
was when you're doing
these things physically,
and the physics of that
are doing that, you also
do the same thing emotionally.
And there's this
nutty thing that
happens when you're on the Vomit
Comet, when you go weightless,
you get really,
really, really happy.
There's a euphoric feeling.
I read before I went
on the Vomit Comet
that once you're weightless,
you can dream weightless.
And I didn't really
know what that meant,
but there's a feeling
I got during those.
I did, I guess, 26
30 second moments
of weightlessness,
which I guess if you had
that up is about 12 minutes.
And you really feel that,
and you can remember it.
And sometimes when
I'm dreaming now,
I dream that I'm floating
around, which I never
was able to do before.
And now I feel that.
And a lot of people have talked
about that, all the guys that
shot "Apollo 13" talked
about that feeling of being
weightless.
But what I've never
seen anybody talk
about was the feeling I
had when going back up.
Because at that point, I
weighed about 300 pounds.
It means going back up
I weighed 600 pounds.
And you do this real
incredible mood shift.
Because when you
go to 600 pounds
the depression that came over
me in just that 30 seconds
was this huge wave.
So you'd go back and forth
from euphoria to depression.
So now it's been 17 months.
Everything is better for me.
As far as I can tell, there's
almost no willpower required.
A huge amount of willpower the
two weeks, the potato weeks.
A lot of willpower when you
first start eating carefully.
But after about
five or six months,
as you jack into the habit,
and as your microbiome changes
and all of that, it gets
really, really easy.
It's much easier to do stuff
that's really, really hard.
It was much easier for
me to make a major change
than a minor change.
Now, since I wrote the book,
and since I went through this,
a lot of my friends
came on board.
And they're someone
that's keeping a tally,
one of the Penn and
Teller enthusiasts
has been watching people
claiming weight loss.
This is the least
scientific thing.
This is less scientific
than the cootie theory.
Because people self-reporting
on Twitter and in email
is no information at all,
really, because we don't know.
We don't know how many
of them are lying.
Yes, we do.
100% of them are lying.
We don't know how
much they're lying,
but it looks like
about 16,000 pounds
people have lost,
they claim, inspired
by what Cray-Ray has been
talking about on this diet
and stuff.
And it's been a really,
really wonderful thing.
I got a zillion
other things to say,
but I always like to
open up to questions.
Anybody has any questions?
And also on anything.
It can be on anything you want.
I mean, we can't
really be done until I
mention Trump, but go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] weeks.
PENN JILLETTE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: How much potatoes?
PENN JILLETTE:
How many potatoes?
The question is,
"how many potatoes
did I eat in those two weeks?"
I didn't keep track,
but I started out
talking to Cray-Ray going, "you
mean I can eat as many potatoes
as I want?"
He goes, "sure sure, as
many potatoes as you want."
What happens if I eat
a shit ton of potatoes?
Well, it turns
out, even when you
throw in sweet potatoes
and all kinds of potatoes,
you get pretty sick of 'em.
By day three or
four, I was having
two or three potatoes a day.
The first few days it
was probably five or six.
I don't really know
how many I ate.
I didn't keep track of it.
I didn't really intend
to document this at all.
So I didn't really get on board
with the keeping track of this
till a little bit too late.
Oh, now there's a
microphone and everything.
Go ahead.
Ask something.
AUDIENCE: Well,
the first question
is if the microphone works.
I think I got the
answer to that one.
PENN JILLETTE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The
second question is,
the dedication page of
your snazzy new book
just has three numbers on it.
What do those numbers mean?
PENN JILLETTE:
Those three numbers
are the weights of my
wife and my two children.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
Thank you.
PENN JILLETTE: I
thought since it's
a book about weight, that's the
way I should do the dedication.
So that's their
weight at that time.
I believe my wife is lighter,
and my son and daughter
are heavier.
But then again,
they're 10 and 11,
so they should be
getting heavier.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So my question is that I saw the
dramatic change on "Fool Us."
And the first thing
that occurred to me
was all the sleight of hand,
all that stuff is so practiced.
Did that have an effect?
Did you have to relearn where
things are on your body?
PENN JILLETTE: Yes!
Completely.
The weird thing, and this is
something I was so afraid of,
I started out as a
juggler, not as a magician.
And when I first did
all the weight loss--
I should also say.
This is a really important
thing that I just
left off-- during the time
I was losing weight, no
exercise whatsoever.
As little exercise as possible.
You want to exercise.
You need to exercise.
You need to be active.
But not until you're
at target weight.
Because bodybuilding
and losing weight
conflict with each other.
They're fighting
the same things.
So I didn't exercise for the
whole time I was losing weight.
But as soon as I
hit target weight,
I started exercising again.
And what was really
interesting about that
was that once I
started exercising,
health and muscle
came back so fast.
It was just really creepy.
I mean, three or four
weeks of pushups and they
were just increasing
this huge amount.
But the other thing was, when
I first hit target weight,
I really couldn't
juggle for shit.
I'd lost all this--
the muscle memory
had changed with a
different sized body.
Now, that came back
very, very quickly.
But it was probably
a week or two
that I had to practice
pretty heavily to get back
to where I was.
That wasn't so much true for
the minor muscular movements,
for just hand movements
and so on, but certainly
for my bass playing, for all
the stuff that's kind of big.
My voice also changed.
No one seemed to
notice it, but when
I was in the middle of
doing a different audio book
for a friend of mine, and
we went back to do pick-ups
and couldn't do them.
I had absolutely lost
the voice I had before.
It's hard to
describe what I lost.
It lost a different
kind of texture.
Also in a movie I was
doing at the time,
we couldn't go back
we do pick-ups.
We had to reloop the
whole scene if we
were going to change my voice.
Otherwise, you'd
hear me punching in.
It also changed the
way I move on stage.
And it changed the
way I did comedy.
It changed the way
I address people.
There was something--
when I was 300 pounds,
I mean, this is a pun,
but it's also true,
there was a certain
kind of gravity
in just being able to
state something standing
on stage the size of a doorway.
I mean, I'm six foot seven.
And when I was 330
pounds at six foot seven,
you're just a presence.
You're a sculpture.
You're just this big blob.
And I found out that
when I was lighter,
in order to get the
same points across,
there was more movement.
It was just a
different way I stood.
Also, the suits we wear in
the show, the Penn & Teller
suits, the matching
suits, couldn't keep up
with my weight loss.
We had tailors coming in
every couple of weeks.
But it was really hard
to change my clothing.
And although when you
watch a Penn & Teller show,
we hope you're thinking that
there are no costume changes,
there are actually costume
changes on every single bit.
What we do is that the
suit coats we're wearing
are gimmicked.
I mean, gimmicked to the tits.
Not just secret
pockets, but things
that drop things out
of here, and things
that drop out of our sleeves,
and poles, and rubber bands,
and all this stuff that
makes the magic work.
Because we don't really
have magic powers.
So we had to go through and do--
I mean, one of the things when
we're doing our show,
we run off stage,
do a complete suit coat change,
change our vests, run back on,
and the audience just
thinks we stepped off
to get a drink of
water or something.
So we do hidden costume
changes in our show.
And all of that wardrobe
had to be changed.
Also, if anybody is interested
in PR, Glenn Alai, who's
our manager and PR person
standing in the back there,
the long suffering
Glenn, Glenn had
to go through selling a
Broadway show of Penn & Teller
when one of the stars
of the Broadway show
didn't look like what
all the advertising said.
Actually, it's much more
complicated than this,
but one of the things
that happened on Broadway
was when you were
going into the theater,
all the pictures were fat Penn.
Because you wanted people
to come up to see fat Penn.
And when you were
leaving the theater,
all the pictures
were skinny Penn,
because that was
the Penn we wanted
you to see in the future.
So I was really
surprised by the fact
that my juggling skills
changed and had to be adjusted.
And I was also just
surprised at how much
just movement difference
and mood difference and all
of that.
It's a much bigger deal.
And of course some of
this, it's not just--
it may even be the most minor
point may be the loss of fat.
Because the lack of salt,
and oil, and refined grains
in my diet, nobody
knows how much
change that is, but certainly
for my blood pressure,
the salt was a huge thing.
It also changes your
mucus membranes.
That changes a lot of the voice.
The voice change may
be more salt than mass.
I just don't know.
I mean, we don't
have a control group.
We don't still have fat
Penn to compare me to.
AUDIENCE: Let me just--
that's very disconcerting.
So I just wanted to say first
that your magic acts are
indistinguishable from magic.
PENN JILLETTE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And some of my
coworkers are of the opinion
that I kind of eat crazy
because I eat Soylent.
PENN JILLETTE: Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
an opinion on Soylent?
PENN JILLETTE: Yeah,
I was very interested.
Before I started this diet,
I was fascinated by Soylent.
I mean, I always
wanted human chow.
I always wanted to
just be able to-- like
they have monkey chow.
I even tried eating monkey
chow, and then a girlfriend
said she'd never fuck me
again if I ate it again,
so I stopped.
But yeah, Soylent, the only
thing I have against Soylent
is I just don't trust our
science where it is right now.
In theory, I think
that certainly all that
could be synthesized and
done properly in theory.
I just know that one of
the problems-- and this
is so counter what I would
have thought-- but my diet
before, when I would
eat everything, anything
I came across, my diet
was very, very limited.
I ate really fat, sugar.
You know, there's not
any very much difference
between a pizza and a hamburger.
There's not very much
difference between brownies
and a pizza and a hamburger.
You've got all this same
stuff going in all the time.
What I find now is eating
the huge amount of vegetables
I eat-- I mean, the amount
I eat now is unbelievable.
I mean, the salads I
eat are like that big.
One of the things is,
I get bored eating,
because I'm eating so much.
I just eat forkfuls
and forkfuls of salad
with just apple
cider vinegar on it.
No oil, no nothing.
And the different
kind of food I eat,
it's so, so varied that
I really feel like I'm
getting many more nutrients.
And I just don't know if
we know enough right now
to be able to pick all those
nutrients, all those vitamins,
put them into
something like that.
But boy the idea is seductive,
just to make it simple.
Also, I need to do this.
I probably shouldn't
announce this here,
because I'm not sure of it.
But I imagine I'll be
winning a Nobel Prize.
I know.
I'm excited about that.
Stockholm has not
called yet, but I
got the greatest idea
human beings have ever
gotten for a food.
And I'm going to
give you a recipe.
And I can say with a
great deal of pride
that I made this recipe on
Dr. Oz's show and damn nearly
fucking killed him,
which would have
been a real plus
for medical science.
[LAUGHTER]
Here's what you want to do.
And this is rich guy food,
because it's expensive.
But it's so worth, and
you're going to love it.
You take blueberries
and blackberries.
You know those
containers like that big?
If you buy them
at Asswhole Foods,
they're like $7 or something?
You take like six of those
containers, maybe eight.
I mean this is this many
blueberries and blackberries.
That many.
And you wash them
off really good,
in case they've
been near Chipotle.
And you get those really clean.
And you dry them
off a little bit,
but leave them a little bit wet.
That's OK too.
And then you take
cayenne pepper.
Oh no.
No, don't you laugh.
Oh, when you try this, you'll be
feel so stupid for your laugh.
Cayenne pepper, and you put
on too much cayenne pepper.
And you look down and go,
"oh Jesus, that's too much."
Then put on more.
And then you go, "oh fuck.
I've lost my mind.
It's gonna burn my ass forever."
Then a little bit more.
OK.
Because the best thing is,
this will keep your children
and Doctor Oz away from it.
Then you take cocoa powder,
just really bitter cocoa powder.
No sugar, no fat,
no nothing in it--
just the raw,
bitter cocoa powder,
bitter like a jazz
musician at 3:00 AM.
And you put much
too much on there.
And then you shake it up.
And if you do it naked,
it'll look better.
You shake it up so you've got
cayenne, and you've got cocoa,
and you've got blueberries
and blackberries.
And you don't do raspberries,
because raspberries
will fuck you.
Raspberries, they get
too mushy, and also they
get moldy before
they really should.
So fuck you, raspberries.
You taste good.
You taste good,
but not that good.
OK?
Too good looking
to be fun to fuck.
That's what raspberries are.
Stay away from the raspberries.
Fuck them.
Assholes.
But blueberries
and blackberries,
pretty safe, pretty safe fruits.
You mix them up like that, and
when you first bite into it,
it is fabulous.
It is like a flourless
chocolate Mexican rapist.
OK, it's just the greatest
thing in the world.
Now, you're going
to say, "haha, Penn.
That's really stupid.
That many blueberries?
That much cayenne?
That much cocoa?"
You're going to write me
a tweet, I guarantee you,
some of you will say,
saying, "you're right.
Stockholm should be calling.
Nobel Prize for these hot,
spicy, chocolaty good."
And you'll never even
want chocolate cake again.
This is the thing
you'll be craving.
I sometimes eat that big
bowl of blueberries, cayenne,
and chocolate like twice a day.
And you feel great.
And you can even eat too much
of it so you're too full.
And then in five minutes,
you don't feel bad.
It's not like eating
four steaks or something.
You feel really, really good.
So keep that in mind.
You don't have to write
it down, but make sure
when you put the cayenne on,
don't be a wimp about it.
And then when you think it's too
much, a little bit more again.
Someone else have a question?
That question, by
the way, had nothing
to do with the blueberries.
I just wanted to bring that up.
PHIL: I'm pleased
to introduce today--
I have a working mic now.
PENN JILLETTE: OK, OK, OK, OK!
PHIL: No, anyway, thank you
very much for coming today.
We really appreciate it.
PENN JILLETTE: Oh, that
was the last question?
PHIL: Yeah, that was
the last question.
Thank you very much.
PENN JILLETTE: Oh no, he's got--
PHIL: He did, but--
PENN JILLETTE: There's
a revolution here.
PHIL: Yeah, it's a
time issue and all.
AUDIENCE: I heard
something about--
PENN JILLETTE: No, no.
Trump-- the rules
of "Apprentice,"
the rules of "Celebrity
Apprentice" are Donald Trump
throws off the show
anyone he wants to.
So there is no way that anything
that happens on "Celebrity
Apprentice" can be unfair.
There are no rules to the show.
I mean, I don't know.
I'm not a good chess player,
but I can tell you the rules.
I'm not a good poker player.
I can't play Texas hold'em,
but I can tell you the rules.
There are no rules to
"Celebrity Apprentice."
A guy just decides who
goes home and who stays.
So anybody who tells you
there's something unfair
being done-- I'll also say
in defense of "Celebrity
Apprentice," I mean, without
getting too "Rashomon" on this,
I believe that the
portrayal of what happens
is fairly accurate.
I mean, they've got 12
cameras running 20 hours a day
in several different rooms.
They can add anything
they want, but the story
they tell on that show was
consistent with the story
I experienced.
Really, all the bullshit
and conspiracy things
you hear about reality
shows are kind of jive.
People really are that
fucked up and stupid
and they just film it.
So yeah, I guess I don't
get any more questions.
So good night!
Drive safely!